uh political chaos is continuing not
just here but also in sri lanka a
bankrupt country where the economy has
ground to a halt a former finance
minister one of the ruling family was
stopped as he tried to flee the country
uh by checking staff actually meanwhile
there are long queues for fuel joining
us now as she has been always on top of
the story is nicole hi nicole what's
going on there this morning
well you can see some of these massive
cues behind us people here have been
lining up for petrol for three days and
last time sky news was here a couple of
months ago it was just a few hours so it
goes to show how much the situation has
continued to deteriorate economically in
this country people also don't have
enough food and medicine uh the world
bank has said that people here are only
able to get enough food
very rarely one in five people in fact
are not able to um
are not able to get the food that they
need and they're in fact hungry
who do they blame for all of this they
blame the president gotta buy rajapaksa
they want him out now sources have told
sky news that the current prime minister
reynold wik ramasingha has decided that
he will not resign as prime minister
before the president that means that he
will become an interim president for the
next 10 days ahead of parliamentary
elections to elect a new president so
what does all of this mean for people in
sri lanka if it plays out the way that
we expect it to play out it means that
they will have won that the rajapaksa
political dynasty will go down and
that's what people here have been
demanding in protest for months now we
had those extraordinary scenes on
saturday when they stormed the
president's house
they still occupy that house as well as
other key buildings inside the city so
right now people are waiting to see what
the president does on wednesday and if
he does go ahead and resign as he is
expected to do so